this program is brought to you by
Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia edu
Oh
our complete look is that you talked
about the concept of a national level
overseeing of Corrections so Lieber too
and of course I i was a little bit slow
and writing that down so it's not a
direct quote but could you expand
because we want to put with a national
blueprint for how to begin to to solve
this urgent problem that many of us a
regular basis engaging some prayer about
so could you expand on you know what
would that look like and give them all
that we've heard you know what would be
your recommendations more explicitly
well the easiest place to get of course
is it first began to be to note that we
have two systems of correction in the
United States your the state system
which I focus my attention on but we
also have an ecosystem was mostly crime
time for variety of races in federal
prison are there because it draws so
large numbers of people who are engaged
in the drug trade career number than you
can find a safe course I Federal's so
one basically easily yeah over there the
federal courts are under the control of
the federal government and with a
significant number of our even there it
becomes place where writing blueprints
for some of the program just heard of
that and gets find out because they are
subject to federal dollars as opposed to
the vagaries of local dollars so I'm
always sort of leads it if you have two
programs that are successful and you're
ready to expand them you don't have to
reinvent wheel that's yes that's over
here yeah and say we've already got
blueprints that we know work and would
obviously be out
cause you are right of communities so I
would begin their the second day of
course is all about money that is being
bound up in a variety of singles titles
some of what you're going to see that
involves the capital improved some of
our prison facilities right now city
california had built in prison i believe
in the last 20 years but that system
continues to be old crowd again i don't
want to try to get into a dialogue where
i'm suggesting that we're going to have
more inmates therefore we need to have
prisons hot stuff back but i'm saying
that a large part of what we're hearing
is people getting out with a sense of
hopelessness literally because they've
been subjected to conditions and
improving quality of life there and
putting into place educational
opportunity programs training program
discharge planning that allows people to
be more closely connected to the
community service in return those are
all parts of solutions that people have
demonstrated work and what we need to do
is has been pointed out simply developed
will say this is where right now I'm
afraid the National below as much more
towards punishment that is on the
equalization now what I'm going to ask
people to do is if you have a suggestion
or vision for what this national
blueprint might look like or question
that you line up at one of the two
microphones and be patient now one of
the things that I'm going to say is that
I'm also representing kind of the mental
health component on this panel panel and
so what I'd like to just add is that
there's another model program that we
see here in New York City project reload
and part of the discharge planning
actually evolves representatives from
Raj Aquino going to the prison's
interviewing those who have a mental
illness plus a chemical abuse disorder
so they're the mentally ill chemical
abusers micra clients and basically they
are then play
in apartments that are in supervised
residences and they can stay there as
long as that they are on parole so for
example someone from five years parole
can also get some provision for their
medication a psychiatrist comes and
assesses then provides their
prescriptions and it's basically an
excellent model just add that that
anyone else you wanna add anything so
let's just keep moving in terms of
expanding upon what about a national
blueprint like for example mr. assanti
or what do you need for your model to
really be replicated a statewide
nationwide actually I program is being
ready we have a chapter in newark and
also the camp we have married these our
reputation values is designed around a
fraternity concept felt out the delta
sigma theta and in north we worked with
the miss apologies there any foundation
into a person foundation to be able to
develop but is now fathers now under the
door comprehensive central father's the
fact that i was just very proud i
attended the graduation our last weekend
when he graduated succeeded in their
first time out demonstrating our project
we were also in caring and we are now
looking to go to atlantic city already
pennsylvania noise hound and chester and
intensely we just
recently received a call from Toledo
idol and and also South Carolina so and
what we've been able to do is provide
five direct service units as far as of
application packages and sir our work in
South program the file traineeship
program so our legal service program and
our mentoring program and also are what
we call our gems which is a job
education management specialist in
another language it would be job
developers and outreach coordinators but
the Egyptian and infidelity were very
proud of it because ninety percent of
the gems unit came through the program
and we hired so they are the prime
example of what can happen if you just
put your best foot forward in and you
have a support because one of the things
that was talked about earlier was it
health peace and and the spiritual
health then the spiritual thought that
is needed for the minute come out and
we're going to come out when they're in
cost rate is extremely important because
that's foot for those first three months
is so very viable whether that will tell
destroy whether they want to go back to
the three years and that support is that
data if we don't forgot a way to be able
to put that in in position where it is a
part of a stable market program then I
think we become this so is one thing
that you need ongoing support from
corporations or partnerships between the
state funders we need to be able to
increase the incorporation
and this is both of these programs we
need to be able to work one of the
things that we're now suggestion is is
that our congressman in Philadelphia be
with the congressman in north and people
to Congress minicam it so that we can
start being developed for easiness or
the federal level to be able to
ascertain these funds and so that it
will be a continuum of dollars and not
as my brother said earlier I just
project it needs to be something that is
ongoing and sustainable and we need to
institutionalize what we do and it just
can't be for a moment okay very good and
so I know mr. Cruz in terms of
dismantling the wilderness and using
your five please but the 6p of prayer
that 510 and the 500 and how Pat Summitt
has been able to really do something you
talked about your success given some of
the partnerships with corporations that
you for libel in the past but with
churches what is it that you need for
this to really continue in thrive in our
current environment well we always see
more money this is less than us that
we're going to plant z skip all the
other what we're looking at now is
trying to get the church to the most
affordable since they're here since
they've been here and guess what they
will want to try wrong
more violent event has formed it
services might be a very phenomenally
inexpensive way a lot of those persons
who come to us to do the workshops and
so forth have done it at no cost the
churches have given us their venues and
no cause the court the leaders that I
was telling you about they all get paid
it's a ministry which is another level
of committee it also opens another level
of doors that nonprofit Stacey we hope
to go to immediate tri-state a new
jersey-long island connect and do the
same thing giving out information that
is need to get on their feet at the
point of just being released but a step
further was made a broader brush I'm
really the mind of doing more community
assessments I think 500 being an interim
information would probably best serve
the local civil service of parole or law
enforcement agencies if they in fact
really knew what was in that community
what was in their precinct what was
sector eyes in terms of services housing
and so forth so that would be what
releasing the first three months of you
mentioned that all those services to be
so concentrated what happens is that
element in the women hit police they'd
sent all over the city trying to find
out how two thousand times so scary how
you meditating before they get bumped
and refusing they don't know what the
technological issues on the way or
subway they lost the scrubs you know
what if I committed another crime I'd be
better off inside me
oh sweet it's easy so what we'd like to
do is know what to make that information
available not a loser people here at
least put something for providing
services including creating a tight
Catch net around the community make them
anymore where the surfaces as available
available to everyone and people don't
have to travel that far exceeded
probably would like to be an example in
Agrabah so we want to get help we want
to help our measure in terms of some of
our tracking is showing that and I'm
sure we'll all agree on is employment
and housing for the two major issues
that are gonna complain to them and
point enough we need residences the
corporation's to work out how we can get
residences where he gentleman could at
least have a place that you go home for
a long time is an employee freshener
month acclimate them to the changes that
exactly their home communities and in
world and then they were better sorry if
we can build residences as opposed to
our temporary stay or scheldt national I
think they'd have a better saw and let
me just say that when I talked about the
to be hostile I had
I was their arms of police or the courts
broad question where the cupcakes and
the primary audience for the type of
information and just subscribe would be
so that in the meetings with exhibits
they have something to give them other
than harsh words if I go get in trouble
here is your fact in the side well I was
I recently became both es oh yeah Iowa a
offender employments it and I got that
title through a workshop through the
federal probation and parole Association
and then one around touching and do
these trainings for those are providers
at they send anything to be able to
become these OES of a more importantly
than that I mean I'm glad to be of oh
yes but more importantly what I loud at
these and the workshops the probation
department of corrections going back
together with some of them she said out
there is that they're looking for
collaboration they're looking for the
answer they are looking to be able to
change early years of a mindset a lot
more throw away the key the little saint
people that working on probation
apartments and department writing every
day and and and as a community we really
need to be able to address the federal
probation parole address corrections
because they are looking to make some
level change which is which is a very
difficult for an individual that has
been sitting in our office and his only
reference is a lot of protein ok so I'm
going to sum up in 45 seconds that we
really need to have
of some kind of federal oversight that
there might be mandates for discharge
plans for example that might be
replicated on state levels that we need
to really ask our churches that to
fulfill their mission and
responsibilities as our most profitable
nonprofits located the community that
the most successful thing we have to
draw up my historically is the presence
of the black church and that they could
really use their resources to assist for
example and heavy and continuing to
support a weekend model of workshops job
fairs where incarcerate where indigent
men can come and get all the information
they need and I nearly 50 i believe
employ some weight with columbia that we
also expand that model so that we would
have booklets that some of you might
volunteer to help create so that parole
officers have on their desks fifty a
hundred copies of these both lists at
they hand to those little roll instead a
year this is where you can get certain
services that black churches will also
have afternoon workshops who they are on
a regular ongoing basis a bring an
indigent men with you after church they
become to the service but they can also
sit down in our nurse at our health
educator and our psychologists who are
members of this church can spend two
hours in afternoon workshop every single
Sunday connecting these men and neck
even to mentors in the church you'll say
I'll teach you about the subway system
here's my cell phone number yes I will
assist you in going to that particular
agency etc Center and that we also see
that there's federal funding and
mechanisms and help to take model
programs like the national companies a
center for father and make them
available
throughout our city states and nation
thank you very much
the preceding program was brought to you
by Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia edu